-How are you, Malcolm?
-I'm doing well, Seth.
How you doing?
-I'm doing well.
Thank you for being here.
And congratulations.
You opened the season
with a win.
I know you've been at this
for a while.
How sore are you on a Monday
after a game day?
-Uh, I'm pretty sore
right now.
But, you know,
you get in the cold tub,
you ice up a little bit
and you're back at it
tomorrow, so --
but nothing out of the norm.
-So last time we spoke,
you were here,
you were a newly crowned
Super Bowl champion.
And now we're speaking after
a game in which you played
in front of no fans.
How was that as an experience
for you?
I mean, again, you've been
playing football
for a long time, but
I'm sure you've never played
in an empty stadium like that.
-Yeah, it's weird.
The first couple drives
felt very much like a practice
or a scrimmage.
They talk about having,
like, crowd noise
pumped in that's
about 70 decibels.
That's like about as loud as --
it sounds like somebody's,
like, vacuum --
vacuuming the stadium.
That's how loud it was.
But you know, at the end of
the day, it was a game
and you start to get into
the competitiveness of it
and you get used to it.
But it definitely was
a weird feeling
not having
your fan base there.
-I know this summer,
you had expressed some doubt,
some hesitation about playing
this season.
Now that you're a week into it
after a very obviously weird
training camp and no preseason,
how comfortable do you feel
with the protocols
and safety measures
that are in place?
-Yeah. I think there's
been a lot of ground
that's been made up
since the spring,
when we really didn't
know much about
what our protocols
were going to be.
A lot of it was negotiated
between our player union
and the league.
And I think we've gotten to
a point where, you know,
guys feel comfortable,
we're getting tested every day.
The positive tests have been
really, really low.
So I think guys
are comfortable,
but that came about through
a lot of negotiating,
a lot of pushing and pulling.
And you know, I'm glad
we created an environment
that at least allows some guys
to feel as safe as possible
as we try to play this game.
-So, we also spoke
before about your foundation.
And this is basically
an organization
that's trying to serve
underserved communities.
And in a time like this,
you know, we always find out
when something along the lines
of a pandemic happens,
it of course affects
underserved communities
disproportionately.
I assume you have to
shift your focus
and the way you approach
helping people out.
Have you found that
to be the case
during these incredibly
difficult last six,
seven months?
-Yeah.
I think to what you alluded,
you know,
whenever you have these
national crisises,
you know, often times the
communities that are already
disadvantaged are --
get it the worst.
And also, so does those
nonprofits that, you know,
help those communities.
And so, for us,
we've had to pivot
not -- you know, as with social
distancing
and a lot of the restrictions.
We have a lot of
in-person programs.
And what we did was say, "Okay,
how do we make this virtual
and turn all of this into
the needs of today?"
And so, we are creating
an online curriculum,
an e-curriculum that kids
can go and experience for free
and get job training
and job readiness,
not only for kids
who are going to go off
to four-year universities
but also those who are going to
take those nontraditional paths
and go directly
into the workforce.
And so, we're doing that and
trying to not preach to kids
at what they should be,
but really give them
opportunities to see
other people
who have taken these paths
and have been successful,
so they can see themselves
as creatives,
see themselves
as entrepreneurs,
and really pursue
those types of paths.
-You're also a producer now,
and one of the things
you've produced
is this really eye-opening
documentary that I think
allows voices that you're
not used to hearing
tell their stories.
You were originally supposed
to be just one of the subjects
in this documentary.
And can you talk about
the path from that
to ending up
on the producing side of it?
-Yeah. I mean, the film --
I was supposed to just
be interviewed,
and it was about kind of this
spectrum of black boys
and their humanity.
And I was intrigued because it
was directed by a white woman.
And she wanted to tell the story
because at some point,
she realized she had a fear
of black men
that she couldn't really
explain.
It wasn't taught to her,
but that she'd just kind of
been conditioned by the things
that she'd seen and been --
you know, how black men
are portrayed.
And I think -- I've had a good
friend tell me recently
when you look at situations
like George Floyd
and how somebody can put
their knee on a man's neck
for eight minutes --
almost nine minutes --
it's because you have to
either see him --
you have to see him either as
superhuman or subhuman.
And often times, when we look
at how we depict black men
and black boys,
it's in those two buckets.
And so there is a wide range
of who we are.
We're not monolithic.
You know, we have creativity,
we are --
we have minds
that are brilliant.
We are creative.
We have fears, we have joys,
we have pain.
And so really just being able
to explore that,
and what does it look like
as early as grade school?
What do our educators look like?
What are the messages that
we're sending our kids?
And really just celebrating
who we are as black boys.
And now, I'm really excited
to do the same
kind of project with
black girls,
because I think they are subject
to a unique experience
that's even, you know,
further kind of
in the depths than black boys.
-Well, congratulations
on the documentary.
You are definitely
as adept a producer
as you are a football player
and an activist.
There's got to be something
you're not good at, Malcolm.
Maybe we can get to it
next time you're here.
-[ Laughs ]
Golf. That's one of them.
-Golf. All right.
Thank you.
You and I, finally we have
something in common.